Naperville Florida is on the line Pamela
is with us hi Pamela how are you great
how about yourself better than I deserve
what's up well I've been listening to
your show and especially the first hour
today and where you were asking parents
you know if their children are willing
to listen to the teachings well I have a
21 year old who is just god-awful with
money he doesn't have any debt yet but
he's working not quite full-time not
going to school and he can't make it
paycheck to paycheck by the end of the
first week his paychecks gone and he
doesn't get paid for another week and
then he's trying to mooch money off of
me or his father or whatever and I'm
wondering what kind of advice you have
other than taking him out back and
beating him over parents like me that
are struggling you know what is he what
does he live he lived in my house oh
okay see that changes the equation if
he's 21 he lives on his own and he can't
make his bills then you would come
alongside him as you would a friend
let's say you're one of your friends had
a kid that was 21 wouldn't make it his
bills what would you do with them you'd
sit down with him have a cup of coffee
with him and say hey I noticed you're
struggling with this and I'd like to
help show you how to do this and coach
you a little as an older friend and
that's what that's what you would do if
he wasn't living at home and that's what
you'll do since he is living at home as
your first step and we have gone through
that and you know and so well then I
would revisit it one more time and I
would revisit it with a little more
firmness this time and just say okay
here's the situation we did not do a
good job of teaching you this stuff
because you didn't learn it up until now
that's on us but here's the thing you're
21 now which the law says you're an
adult it's questionable but the law says
you're an adult and so the situation is
this we're going to show you how to
budget and you're going to learn how to
budget and you need to do that because
that's what's good for you because you
can't win living like you're living now
you're either going to do that
voluntarily or we're going to make it a
condition of you continuing to live here
you're gonna have to move out if you
don't do this okay because I'm going to
make you learn how to do this and by the
way that's not us punishing you or
controlling you this is what's known as
an act of love because you're you're not
you don't have the life skills to make
it in the big boy world and so we're
gonna walk with you and give you those
life skills because we care about your
son
and we're gonna put our arm around Jen
we're gonna walk with you and you're
going to accept our assistance and
coaching and you're gonna go along with
that because that's how you're gonna pay
rent and if you don't do that then your
rent is behind and you'll be evicted and
so you have two choices move out so that
you have the freedom to continue your
stupidity or accept our coaching and
we'll consider that as your rent paid in
full
very calmly and just kindly and and and
I don't know how rebellious or
strong-willed he is with my kids that I
wouldn't have had trouble with that if
my parents had done that as wild as I
was I wouldn't move down cuz I was
stupid yeah and he's stupid so he
probably will end up moving out and he
won't have a car because we provide him
one yes no he's required to do is pay
his insurance every month yeah and so
you don't get that cuz it's in my name
and so you're gonna find out how life
really works you're gonna be like a
homeless guy that's what's coming up
Bubba so hopefully hopefully but but
listen you and your husband you got to
go away and talk about this for a few
hours and nail this down because the
you're gonna feel like bad parents or
something and you're not bad parents
well the biggest problem with that is my
husband is not his father
okay we're a blended family well then
you've you've really got to be on the
same page and how long has your husband
how long have you been married to your
her current husband 12 years okay so
he's been very involved in the raising
of this young man absolutely
and and how is their relationship it is
strained because my husband
very forceful with his teaching and with
his expectations he's retired military
well I would suggest he cranked down the
military a few notches and and put a
little softness around the edges but and
so let's be a an iron fist in a velvet
glove instead of just an iron fist
mm-hmm because we're not trying to push
the kid out in the cold that's not the
goal here the goal here is to modify his
behavior and get him to make better
choices as a young adult for his own
good
we're not trying to harm it only we're
not trying to harm you but and so your
husband but you can't call that out in
front of this kid ever again you and
your husband have to present a united
front on this subject and you know how
you know the even tone with which I've
been discussing this with you very calm
but very strong that's the type that's
the type of tone your husband and you
would would take because I'm not trying
to set this little firecracker off
that's not my goal here I want to
persuade him and I want you to see what
I'm saying if you want to set the little
firecracker off I know how to do that
just bust up in his face he'll blow up
and head out the door but that's not the
goal the goal is not throwing out the
goals to get him to change I don't want
him to leave I want him to abide by
these rules some days we do what I
believe well you know I left it and I
left home at about that age and went out
and I lived through it and it you know I
it was not it was not you know I was
stupid but you know I was out at 19 as
well when I was rebellious and mean and
redneck and all those things and I had
all that so you know you know I'm 53 now
I lived through it all and but it's not
the best track for him if we can get him
to conform but if we can't get him to
conform he needs to leave and by the way
the days you want him to leave that
means he's doing something that's not
acceptable in your home and those things
got go too
we have a value system in our home and
if you're gonna be under our roof
regardless of what your name is
you're gonna go bye-bye that value
system that's not mean that's called
manners if I came and stayed in your
house I wouldn't do things that you
didn't allow in your house that would be
horrible with me as a guest and by the
way when you're 21
you're a guest I like that theory of it
yeah absolutely and so you just kind of
got to set that stuff back up but you
guys you and your husband poolside kind
of lay out exactly what your
expectations are the conversation and it
might be a good idea if he's already
said too much your husband being if he
was sitting there with you to represent
a united front and then you present the
material you present the lowdown the
ultimatum and and that way maybe he
hears it this time but I but he needs to
hear it and you guys and it doesn't have
to be instantaneous you know we're gonna
give you 30 days because we're kind of
springing this on you but you're gonna
start doing this honey because we love
you and you're not doing this is bad for
you people who live thank God it's
Friday
oh god it's Monday struggle through
their whole lives and we don't want to
watch you struggle through your whole
life you know that's the kind of message
in other words this is about helping him
and he needs to hear that instead of you
throwing him out but yeah it may result
in that but and that'll be an act of
love too because it gets out there and
figures out how hard it is maybe he'll
read a book then you know is that right
absolutely I don't I don't want to take
him out the back yard any motherboard
that he's too old for that doesn't work
I just might take him out in the
backyard and take his keys away and II
can't get back well y'all have fun with
this but you know iron iron fist in a
velvet glove that's what you're looking
for here and so because you are kind of
coming on the scene late with this and
trying to you know insert something into
somebody late in the game it's and then
it's harder to teach an older dog new
tricks but it's also okay if you
lovingly maybe you help him move I don't
mind him moving and you helped him move
you don't have to you know tear the
relationship apart for him to move out
that's not the end of the world and even
with all of that I'm still gonna set the
expectation that in about six months
he's gone he needs to plan to get his
act together and move on in six months
cuz he's been he's been home long enough
and it's good for him it's you know I
got to tell you folks I'm so convinced
Eagles don't fly if I don't leave the
nest I don't fly sitting in the nest an
eagle becomes a turkey they need to
leave the nest they fly spread your
little wings flap them baby flap them
there are rocks below if you don't flap
them flap them and in there's so much
dignity you just can't soar if you don't
leave the nest yes there's there's no
wind there's no updraft you don't get to
see the views you don't have the thrill
none of that there if you don't leave
the nest
you